all right loki is done and before i talk
about it i want to thank the sponsor of
this video this video is brought to you
by bespoke bespoke's a monthly
membership club that delivers boxes with
top shelf goods from under the radar
brands they have a variety of boxes a
cornucopia of options and every box has
70 dollars of value in it but only costs
you 45 and you get a preview of what
your monthly box is gonna be and you can
one
choose to keep it two change it out for
another box or three just skip that
month entirely and don't get a box in
which you won't get charged for that
only get what you're gonna use i
appreciate the fact that they understand
that last time they sent me the flay box
these have become my go-to kitchen
knives i use these knives all the time
this month they sent me the turbo box
which is code for they loaded me up on
coffee i'm not complaining i'm from
seattle we just call this part of a
well-balanced breakfast i mean how do
you think i have this energy in my
videos only half of its hopes and dreams
the other half
coffee oh yeah so click the link below
enter promo code john's 20 at checkout
get yourself 20
off your first box and thank you once
again to bespoke for sponsoring this
video
i do appreciate it all right now we end
the loki odyssey well kind of
spoiler alert i'm getting ahead of
myself gonna be spoilers talking about
the loki finale because that's how i
like to get down when i talk about
episodes of shows
also not gonna be a play by players
always just things i found
interesting just realize that i have
paint i have i don't know if you can see
the warhammer paint
on my hand in painting warhammer
miniatures always wash your hands before
you press
play to do a youtube video which i did
not do also special thank you to
squidmar and all that
helpful information you gave me in your
youtube videos okay but loki right so
the finale of loki is pretty much that
scene in the matrix reloaded where neo
goes to talk to the architects oh
instead of neo
it's loki and sylvie and if the
architect traded in his thesaurus for
that social media generation energy it's
kind of like that he's pretty much like
dude i'm really old i've lived a very
long time and there was a time when
realities would exchange information and
technology for the betterment of all the
realities and then boom multi-reality
super war happened so this whole tva
thing that i came up with
that is the only way that that doesn't
happen which is pretty much a strange
thought like what's gonna happen
what realities are gonna get wiped out
that's what the tva does anyway either
trillions die or trillions just
don't get to exist cement
we're going semantics here he's pretty
much like you kill me you flush all that
down the toilet and silvi says
what sylvie says which is you're a liar
i don't believe you loki and silva get
into a bit of a
tussle then they share the most awkward
kiss in the mcu
possibly then sylvie pushes loki through
the quantum leap door back to the tva
world kills this guy dude's like i'll
see you soon and he dies you see all the
realities branches pretty much that's
the episode in a nutshell but the strong
points in this show definitely
mobius and loki owen wilson and tom
hiddleston they always were in the show
they always remain so in the show they
weren't always together when they
weren't together i wish
they were together on screen together
how many times can i string that word
together and say together together
i don't know we're gonna find out
together that was borderline dad joke
i'm sorry that's just called setup so
later on when i talk about oh things
that didn't really stick the landing for
me and the show you guys can go ah but
he did crack a dad joke it makes sense
when this show had them working as
agents in that buddy cop kind of dynamic
i loved it also some things that were
interesting concepts were those things
that even though i saw them coming
i was still interested you know it's
still i like that hook
example the tva granted there was
someone behind the whole thing i thought
maybe it might just
be nothing i thought maybe they'd just
dogmatically be following these rules
because
someone told them to do it and someone
told them to do it before that it's like
that button and lost it's like oh you
gotta push the button
in season two of loss though that also
ended up being for a reason but i was
most
interested in that concept and lost and
here was like
maybe there's maybe nothing will happen
maybe it's just because someone
told somebody that's just it's always
been fascinating to me well people do
stuff because they just
kind of heard that that should be the
way the answer is yes but the show
didn't go there that's fine but i do
like the fact that the tva there is a
flip where it's like
they're kind of the bad guys the concept
of silvia is actually really interesting
this other loki from this other reality
who's just gonna burn the system to the
ground again that struggle between
concept and execution the concept of
this lady who's been pursued by the tva
all her life is an interesting concept
completely eclipsed by the fact that she
feels like she was conjured to be some
loki romance that i just
didn't buy as a romance between the two
of them i by the concept that they're
war buddies they're working together to
get this thing done but you know
while they friend zone each other
because it feels like that happened
granted half of that is also on the
other side of it i don't buy
loki's redemption in a week and a half
or however long this show goes on for i
get that he saw a sizzle reel of his
eventual neck snapping at the hands of
thanos
and his death thus his life is a
complete joke it's a complete waste of
time but i feel like you know he's been
the god of mischief for
a very long time many of our lifetimes
feel like he'd be like yeah but that was
that reality
i can do it better now that i know that
that's where it's going to end
you'll see i'll be the true god of
mischief but no he's just kind of
reformed
on a snap week and a half ago he's all
like i won't touch barton
not until i make him kill you slowly
intimately in every way he knows you
fear
and then he'll wake just long enough to
see his good work
and when he screams i'll split his skull
this is my bargain you mewling quim week
and a half later oh you look cold here
borrow my blanket let me warm you i'm
concerned but i do feel like this show
could have been a movie you know this
could have been an mcu movie
titled loki as seen with the fact that
there were at least two episodic
filler episodes that didn't have to be
their own episode one the grimace
episode i call it the grimace episode
because it's
big purple and generally speaking
useless the other one being the one
where after loki gets pruned he goes to
that world where the big smoke monster
from lost is gonna eat them this episode
is one of those episodes you can point
to
and be like that's what i'm talking
about when i say there were parts of
this show
that felt like they just wasted our time
for the sake of having a lot of easter
eggs and
references and that's it that's the
reason oh there are a lot of loki's that
could be
cool but they didn't do anything they
were just there so they could have a
really interesting looking loki
in the thumbnails of some of the videos
you didn't need any of the loki's except
old loki he didn't need kid loki
alligator loki
election loki his entourage of other
loki's but moments like that keep the
machine turning it keeps the chatter
happening
it's like the old adage all press is
good press and by press i mean twitter
conversations
tweets and youtube videos that's that's
what gets it happening oh all these
loki's what are they gonna do i'll make
a youtube video about it you see the
thanos copter in the background oh
frog thor and that gets the tweets
against the youtube videos
youtube videos about all the easter eggs
in that episode because that's
where the chatter comes from but that
was a pretty sweet reveal when loki goes
to mobius when he's back in the uh the
tva and he's like okay we just killed
the guy
and now things are gonna happen mobius
is like who are you and
why are you telling me this and they
look out and you see that kang the
conqueror statue pretty sweet reveal
though the entire time it was they were
going to kill whoever was behind this
they were going to release the timeline
from the grip
of whoever had it because doctor strange
in the multiverse of madness was
happening how crazy would that have been
would have been one of the
goat moves of any studio ever of all
time if in the whole phase 4 reveal
instead of having doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness revealed
it was doctor strange and something else
just give it some fake titles some other
title dr strange the sorcerer supreme
whatever you want to call it then at the
end of loki after the timeline
is fractured after it's released from
this grip post credit scene it has that
doctor strange title
of sorcerer supreme or whatever that
just shifts around like multiverse of
madness and that's the reveal it's like
oh no this doctor strange movie's
actually called
the multiverse of madness bulldo would
have been a pretty sweet move
also would have kept the suspense going
a little more in the show loki also
would have been mad props if they
could have kept that under wraps in this
social media age
and i'm looking forward to seeing this
badass version of kang that is a
different kind of reveal
in terms of the mcu where it's like you
show the character but it's this
weird character then it's like okay now
you're gonna see that character later
but he's gonna be business and he's here
to wreck some i guess
that's like first meeting thanos but
he's a circus clown at some kid's
birthday party or something and then oh
by the way
other reality thanos and you know that
guy that could be some really sweet
payoff looking forward to seeing that so
in the end loki i mean ups and downs all
the mcu
shows have had ups and downs loki's no
different but i do think they overplayed
the hand of references for the sake of
references and easter eggs for the sake
of easter eggs like having episodes just
completely built around them feeling
like it kind of wasted time
loki in his own show never has a moment
where i'm like oh that was his moment
it's just
the show just kind of happened and he
was in it which i think is wasteful
because he's one of the more interesting
characters in the whole of the mcu i've
enjoyed loki fine though i've had some
gripes i know people don't like to see
gripes they want to see me gush about
the marvel stuff i totally get it but
you know you gotta be honest you gotta
be true to yourself possibly on popular
opinion and i'm only seven episodes in
but so far
i think superman and lois is better and
i don't even mean that in terms of
marvel vs dc kind of capacity i say in
the capacity of character development
and character story
and easter eggs and references that can
be in there but they don't supersede
that character development and character
story so those are my thoughts on the
show loki
season one anyway because as i said at
the end of this show there's gonna be a
season two so loki have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]
you